um so you would why didn't you adopt
first you adopted first right we did I
always talked about adopting my whole
life my mom is actually adopted and I
thought it was really cool and so we
talked about it off and on but it wasn't
something that we had sat down and had
like a full on adoption conversation um
and then I was in Uganda in 2016 and um
I had a picture of one of the babies
there and I had shared it on social
media and when I finally got to FaceTime
him that night he I was telling him her
story and I was like babe we know so
many people who are trying to adopt
right now and this little girl needs a
forever home and I was like so moved
maybe the second I touched her it was
like electric and I was like oh my word
this little girl has just taken my heart
and I was like honey we've got to find
her her forever home like I know that's
why I'm here is to get this girl to her
home and oh my god okay he totally
opened me just now you touching me home
to me it doesn't matter if it's yours or
not we're a blended family you in your
life this is this is my that's my
purpose it's such a powerful thing so
how did that turn into y'all adopting
well just when I talked to her on the
phone that night and she said that we
need to find her a home I literally it
was after a concert and I was going to
bed and I was like we'll bring her home
and I don't fully remember even saying
it like it was like such a spiritual
thing for me that it just came out of my
body and then literally two weeks after
we were having you know home assessments
and and talking to adoption agencies and
Wow
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my Channel please don't
make me keep going